many drugs have been used in young
people that have never been studied it's
surprising
that we would we do it it is happening
unfortunately
it definitely does seem crazy um when i
stopped
some of the symptoms i had were like
about about two weeks after i stopped
i hallucinated and i've looked it up
it's like what the hell was that
that didn't happen before i started
taking ssris
and there are papers saying you can have
you know visual disturbances
after you stop taking ssris but it was a
full-on hallucination
i was like that's what was that um
and then i've i've just noticed over so
i stopped taking them when i was 23 and
i'm 29
and it's just my brain just keeps
functioning better
like the longer i am off of those it's
better and better
and i've had some psychometric testing
done and that's changed
in a positive manner so it's just it's
unbelievable